Carla Harris's husband is on a mission
second gentleman Doug imhoff stirring up
debate on the role of men in society oh
my gosh after a bashing toxic
masculinity
as being second gentlemen changed your
own view of perceived gender roles of
what it means to be a man
that's this is something I've I've
thought about a lot and something I've
spoken about a lot there's too much of
toxicity it's masculine toxicity out
there and we've kind of confused what it
means to be a man what it means to be
masculine where you've got this Trope
out there that you've got to be tough
and you know angry and and lash out to
be strong I just the opposite
of all the issues
in all the world
this is the issue he's choosing I think
he's not busy enough Greg oh this is
getting a lot of traction uh because of
you know the VP claims he's continuing
to speak out against toxic masculinity
has anybody ever heard him speak ever I
haven't maybe that's how he fights toxic
masculinity by keeping his pretty little
mouth shut unless he's kissing Dr Jill
ah well I think it was shut wait was it
are you sure
um you remember when he complained that
Kamala Harris didn't have good enough
assignments and he was he let people
know In The West Wing like she should
and we thought look hey you should just
be happy to be there but he had a
thriving law practice and now he's there
what's he doing and he decides this is
the issue not like and there's no
economic help for people out in the
countryside like he chooses this I mean
there's literally a toxic train wreck
yeah in Ohio he's talking about talking
about some free legal aid for some
people there's nothing Lamer than a man
bemoaning toxic masculinity
men are not toxic society's toxic and
look what you've done to us you've taken
our guns
you say our trucks are killing the
environment
all the jobs you sent to China and then
you bring in all of Latin America to do
the rest of them
and then you push us into cubicles where
we're not even allowed to date our
colleagues and we can't even crack jokes
with our colleagues or else we'll get
hauled into HR if we want to be a police
officer we're called racist a coal miner
or a
Keystone pipeliner they'll cancel your
job they mock you on TV
tear down our statues they say meat is
bad for us and if you lift weights
you're a white supremacist and if you
play golf you have white privilege
so if you don't like his wife you're
sexist so then they tell us to tell us
your feelings and then we say you know
what this is how I feel men and women
are different and then and then they
call us transphobic perfect well done
Jesse I don't feel like we could leave
it there oh I'm sorry I can't leave it
there if you know why yes no of course
not I just meant that it was very good
um literally any issue they could have
chosen and also it's like helping a
cause that is only for like the very
liberal online people Democrats that are
on Twitter like who is this expanding
are you I am a little surprised by this
one I have to say well here's the thing
Jesse the truth is that when men became
non-toxic and non-masculine and all that
it forced us to take that on so now we
the women have toxic masculinity
um but you know the truth is that I
didn't know who he was and I think most
people have no idea who the guy is and I
don't know why he referred to that
something must have happened in this
life where he got up and said I got to
talk about this or maybe the first time
he thought about it was when this guy
asked him the question I mean it's not
anything that needs attention and most
men that I know who are really masculine
don't raise their voice they don't they
they don't have to beat their chest they
don't have to do that you know so I
don't know why he's talking or who's
listening Jessica was this maybe
something that they think is good for
the 2024 campaign is there a clamor for
this I don't think so I I don't know
um but it doesn't seem like a bullet
point that we necessarily needed if
people were saying you know which party
is about
you know it's a democrat-centered
message right and we have a female vice
president for the first time so everyone
knows that that's something that's
important to us
um and he's obviously supportive of his
wife which I think is great but
contextualizing it into this broader
thing when it's not necessarily a policy
area that you can own and win which is
what he was saying about Kamal right she
needs something that can be finished
like when Joe Biden had gay marriage
the Supreme Court decision happened and
that was something that was a bow on she
has the Border she could try I think
it's toxic masculinity to expect her to
do something you know what right it's
like what why are we imposing masculine
standards of achievement on women that's
a good point good thank you I think I'm
gonna run with it all right good I want
to be judged by last two all right I
want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now